vous êtes devenu un acteur vous qui êtes
à un enfant du nord est les gens du nord
ont une fausse réputation qui leur colle
à la peau doit être des gens très très
drôle vous en a pour apporter le démenti
aussi il y en a une série de thierry
scheid du nord aussi alors ça a commencé
comme ans pour vous je je je crois
savoir que vos parents étaient pas du
tout favorable à ce que vous deveniez un
rigolo non je vais vous dire c'est
toujours des carrières d'acteurs c'est
toujours le hasard je devais de
pharmaciens et à cause de la guerre
tout a été décalé et puis j'aimais ce
métier là je faisais ddd petit numéro
dans des dîners de communion et les
mariages tout ça et puis ça m'amusait
beaucoup mais quand j'ai annoncé à mes
parents c'était un petit peu le côté
bourgeois ont des métiers de bohémiens
tu vas pas partir comme ça c'est des
gens parce qu'ils avaient les acteurs à
cette époque laver la réputation d'être
des gens paresseux c'est pas pourquoi
ils pouvaient traiter de paresseux et
mes parents m'ont autorisé à se faire ce
métier à une seule condition que ce soit
dans la musique moi c'était plus noble
oui c'est considéré comme plus de
musique classique attention pas la
chansonnette et comme je chantais
j'avais une voix de basse
j'ai commencé à préparer le
conservatoire de valenciennes d'abord
après le conservatoire de l'est après le
conservatoire de paris en disant ça
m'amuse beaucoup de chanter l'opéra mais
vous contourner l'obstacle
voilà je maryse et comme on disait à
cette époque ça sera une occasion de
monter à paris
et puis alors après après avoir ce ce
premier prix au concert vous avez le
premier prix tout le matin vous souvenez
de la chanson que vous chantiez a assez
des mama chanson fétiche c'est l air de
la calomnie du barbier de seville
d'ailleurs qu'on va
retrouvez dans jribi pour chanter comme
ça oui c'est homme-là tellement demandé
de chanter
après ce couac des élus sont et c'est le
leitmotiv
alors ça commence comme ça c'est d'abord
vu meurent les joueurs voilà alors 6ème
alors que je vous fais quelque chose
d'extraordinaire en saluant un moment
puis celle au bien alors après lille
vous êtes monté à paris ça y est je suis
monté à paris
je me suis présenté au conservatoire de
paris
je n'avais pas beaucoup d'espoir parce
qu'à l'époque il y avait il y avait 30
places et il y avait mille concurrents
enfin j'ai eu un coup de bol je suis
rentré quand même et avec le maire grâce
toujours avec les as du barbier de
seville et un jour on trouvait au
conservatoire en trouver quelques
méchantes a été mauvais comédiens et
chanteurs d'opéra et il y avait un
professeur de comédie qui était très
connu en estimant il me dit écoute moi
évidemment tu as une belle voix mais moi
tu me fait marrer d'étape à la tête qui
va avec ta voix tu ferais une carrière
mon avis comme comique qui fera une
carrière beaucoup plus importante que le
champ et il croyait me faire de la peine
mais il me faisait énormément plaisir
je lui ai dit d'ailleurs il m'a dit
alors écoute tu viens mes cours il a été
merveilleux m'a dit tu viens mais court
tu ne paiera pas il y en a d'autres qui
paieront pour toi et tu viens parce que
à mon avis tu un cas intéressant et
alors évidemment quand j'ai annoncé à
mes parents c'était le désespoir ils
m'ont dit c'est fini tu seras un
bohémien toute ta vie on veut plus de
voir ils vont fermer les portes qu'aux
carrément été la brouille la rupture la
haute thur maintenant il aurait ouvert
un peu oui ça va mieux ça va un peu
mieux depuis combien de temps
ben ça fait 7 8 ans pour beaucoup depuis
que ça va bien dans la région comme ça
bien
alors maintenant tout le monde se
souvient évidemment vous avez débuté
comme
chanteur vous fait chanter facilement
vous chantez l'enchère et bibi ça nous
aurons l'occasion de le voir dans cours
des chiffres mariage encore voyager
compte de nommer communions baptêmes et
vous chantez aussi à la télévision quand
on vous le demande si vous voulez bien
nous allons regarder une séquence qui
date de 1969 l'émission s'appelle le
château des chansons et vous chanter
parce que ça me donne du courage vous en
souvenez vous voyez ça fait plaisir je
m'en souviens vaguement et je serai ravi
de revoir ça alors nous regardons
ensemble
on
dans le facteur part en tournée on
entend toute la matinée pour tenir au
fond
ah là là parce que ça lui donne du
courage salmeron et le coeur à l'ouvragé
il le peintre en bâtiment quand il
repart l'appartement chanter
t mon
l'heure de guillaume tell sur sa grotte
des chaînes parce que ça lui donne du
courage salle wihr mais le coeur à
l'ouvragé mais le notaire on va passer
avec son oeil que la crise a fait une
serviette son pardessus et son aide au
passé à 100 les murs du vieux lit c'est
un petit pas prêt c'est un guy les
traits
et c'est
alors moi quand ça ne va pas bah j'ai
compris je chante comme ça ralala l'onu
ai hâte que ça me donne du courage ça me
met le corps alpha santé cac
et ce en pleine pas de troupes
sans amour les gens semblent
m
sans ce coup
bien alors après cette chanson jean
lefebvre chéri bibi qui va commencer cet
après midi sur tf1
c'est un bon souvenir pour vous c'est un
très bon souvenir
et malheureusement danse est toujours
dans les bons souvenirs il ya des g ou
la tournée ça avec hervé sans vous savez
qui les dernières l'année dernière et ça
m'a fait beaucoup de peine parce que
c'était c'est idiot de dire ça dès qu'on
meurt on a toujours toutes les qualités
mais et avait c'en est un un gars
extraordinaire d'une simplicité très
consciencieux dans son travail
toujours prêt à rigoler malgré on a eu
des moments difficiles on a tourné sa
une période où il faisait très froid il
a toujours été merveilleux c'est c'est
touchant que par l'aide de gens comme ça
comme et et bourvil d'ailleurs que je
connais aussi gérer bibi c'est un long
tournage donc assez difficile dans les
conditions difficiles à une époque un
peu difficile et vous vous incarnez quel
personnage la ficelle méfie salle
c'est très curieux parce que les enfants
quand l'émission elle a déjà passé cette
émission et les enfants dans la rue
c'était la ficelle ne connaissait que
sous le nom de la ficelle bien alors
nous allons donc retrouver la ficelle
chaque samedi sur tf1 en épisodes de 52
minutes ce qui est une bonne chose je
crois c'est mieux dans notre avis de
même que jean pignol que cette série
passe en morceaux plus important 52
minutes donc et vous serez la ficelle je
pense qu on vous appellera certainement
encore plus la ficelle dans la rue de
temps en temps à partir de maintenant je
serais ravi ses dirigeants merci
[Musique]